hey everybody its charlie I've been
getting a lot of requests to do a new
Superman Man of Steel video and because
they're in the middle of Aquaman reaches
right now I figured like this is a good
time to do a big DC update because we
have all the Shazam stuff going on and
if you haven't noticed they've actually
been running a stealth Superman
marketing campaign in the background
across both of these things mostly with
the Shazam movie because I think he's
more deeply linked to that but they also
just added a brand new character to the
Aquaman movie and reshoots and tied in a
huge Man of Steel Easter egg so they're
like working Superman into these other
DC movies because we don't have Man of
Steel 2 yet so you kind of start to see
how they plan on using Superman until we
get to that next Man of Steel movie so
I'll explain that Superman Easter egg in
the Aquaman movie and then sort of like
this backdoor Shazam stuff that's going
on if you're finding me for the first
time be sure to subscribe to get all the
videos there have been a lot of updates
about the flash movie so I'll just do a
separate video about that when we have
some news but the first big Superman
Easter egg inside this Man of Steel
movie is through Randall Parks character
you may have seen that James Wan the
director posted a picture with Randall
Parks that you know so happy to bring
him to our movie juice uh Momoa posted a
picture from behind the scenes you see
this blue screen down here the row most
done with additional photography right
on schedule to drop a trailer at Comic
Con because the movie is not coming out
to the end of the year so they're
usually about six months out when they
start rolling trailers but Randall Park
is actually playing Steven shin he's a
scientist Ally who's been a lifelong
friend of Aquaman's human father that
helps Aquaman develop his powers Walt is
growing up more recently in the new 52
he had something of a villain spin where
he gets really pissed off at Aquaman for
not revealing the secret location of
Atlantis it kind of takes on a mad
scientist spin where he helps Aquaman
find a dangerous monster and take him
down but then he wants to use the
monster for science and Aquaman won't
let him so we don't really know how
they're gonna use the character in the
movies if he's just gonna be his friend
and Ally growing up or if he's gonna be
somebody that's gonna help him out with
something small in present day because
it's additional photography it implies
that most of the movie has already done
usually low-level reshoots or just to
provide some context
for character turns like if ocean master
really hates Aquaman because of
something that Aquaman did but it's not
totally clear why that event was so
significant to ocean master that I had
like a couple lines of dialogue here
there just to clarify that that's really
what it winds up being unless you're
like a Fantastic Four movie and they
wind up completely reshooting the third
act of the film but in this picture of
Randall Park he's in costume because
there's a slip of paper in his pocket
that reads existence of Superman me that
he's one of those people like Lois Lane
during the Man of Steel movie that
believed that a Superman exists but they
haven't proven it yet so no idea where
this exists in the timeline like if this
is gonna be a flashback to before the
Man of Steel movie or if it's gonna be
sometime during those events but you get
an idea for how they're weaving this
into the larger universe
so whatever Aquaman's journey is during
the Aquaman movie Superman will exist
and obviously the Aquaman movie is gonna
jump around in time because they're
gonna tell his backstory a little bit
you'll learn the history of Atlantis
you'll learn was happening in present
day for the most part this is taking
place after the Justice League movie
because like you remember during Justice
League he has that conversation with
Mira where she seems really pissed off
that he doesn't want to have a lot to do
with the Atlanteans in their way of life
like oh you decided to grace us with
your presence all right at last the
firstborn beloved Queen atlanna wait
please I knew her
next one of us when my parents fought in
the wars she took me what a saint you
dare speak of Queen atlanna that way
you're a queen by family my father's
doorstep and never gave another thought
your mother left you to save your life I
cannot imagine how we hurt her
what it cost her but you're not a
defenseless child now it would have been
her responsibility to follow that
monster to the surface and stop it now
it's yours but I'm gonna need something
from you so while Henry Cavill right now
has been spending most of his time
promoting the Mission Impossible movie
and I don't think that he just has a lot
of physical time to actually go and
shoot a ton of scenes for the Aquaman
movie I do think they're gonna try
include him in a really small way that
could be is Clark Kent he could just be
investigating stuff there could be some
funny tag scene where he has a brief
moment he could even appear on a screen
in the background of a scene that like
Black Manta or one of the other human
characters is in so you have to shoot
new footage with Superman you use him in
the film so you sort of invoke him
without directly making it a big
crossover film because it's still
Aquaman's film it's not like Superman's
gonna swim down to Atlantis and save the
day like this is all about Aquaman
winning the throne of Atlantis from
ocean master so when we're talking about
them ceding Superman and all these other
DC movies that are coming up in the next
couple of years that's really what I'm
expecting from him before we get to the
Man of Steel movie he's not gonna have a
ton of screen time until that next
Superman solo film but the Shazam movies
so you've probably heard me talk about
Superman and Shazam there's been a
theory for a long time and I think
there's more than enough evidence to
prove that he's gonna have like an
actual physical on-screen role in a
really small way because you literally
have Freddie Freeman walking around in a
Superman t-shirt with the Superman Man
of Steel logo this takes place after the
Justice League movie so like all these
little kids look up to Superman as a
hero wouldn't it make sense that he
would appear in like a really small way
either in the background they watch him
do some
tbh like oh my god did you see Superman
save that person then somehow invoke his
larger interest because if there's a
character is powerful as Billy Batson
inside the DC Universe wouldn't Superman
pay him a visit like look you're a
weapon of mass destruction I need to
find out what your deal is
it's like Doctor Strange in the Marvel
movies like he keeps a watch list of all
the most dangerous magical creatures if
they come to Planet Earth so I keep a
watch list of individuals and beings
from other realms that may be a threat
to this world
sure top did brother Loki is one of
those beings were the inclusion yeah so
if Superman is protector of the entire
planet like he probably keeps tabs on a
lot of these bigger more powerful beings
including Aquaman and what's going on at
Atlantis it's just that we haven't
gotten to that movie yet so there hasn't
been a lot of time to reference what's
going on there so hopefully this gives
you a little idea for how these movies
are crossing over the movies we'll use
him in really fun ways but he's still
gonna be a relatively background
character because this year is
Superman's 80th anniversary so while
there's a lot of comic-book stuff
happening Bendis is doing action comics
1,000 with a bunch of other DC writers
and artists henry cavill will also be
doing a lot of Superman stuff in the
background too even though he doesn't
actually have a Man of Steel movie
coming out but just I mean wait for
Comic Con we might hear something about
Man of Steel too by the time we get
there if you haven't been following any
of Zachary Levi Instagram posts or as a
live streams Henry Cavill will regularly
check in and comment and troll on his
post mostly poking fun just like having
fun with him like who's your favorite
superhero or he'll compliments him on
his workouts so it's sort of a fun way
for him to interact with the fans via
these other movies and just remind
people hey Superman is a big character
in the movie universe he continues to
exist I continue to play him even though
you may not have heard when my next
movie is coming out but if we already
know a little bit about what's going on
with Henry Cavill in the Shazam movie
what do you want them to do with the
character in the Aquaman movie just like
brief appearance do you want a
post-credits scene or do you actually
want to have a scene between Aquaman and
Superman in the actual film believe all
your DC video requests in the comments
below there's some flash finale stuff we
learned about the TV show that
next week but click here for brand new
infinity war and click here for that
Shazam livestream where they talk about
Superman a whole bunch thank you so much
for watching everybody to stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]